it's nearly two years since I first went
to Greece to report on the plight of
hundreds of children from war zones
youngsters who'd made it to a safe
country but were unable to get the
medical help they needed one particular
case that of Najib Ali from Syria was
heartbreaking the 13 year old was
paralyzed
and in a wheelchair after being caught
in an air strike his condition was
getting worse as each month passed by
the UK charity goodwill Caravan vowed to
help Najib and Sky News viewers moved by
his pain donated tens of thousands of
pounds towards his care this is the
story of what became of Najib
Najeeb was a nine-year-old boy living
happily with his family and the
airstrikes began in their town they
pronounced him dead when they wrapped
him up to bury him his mother saw a
pulse on his ankle and she screamed to
the doctor that he was alive after the
airstrike Najeeb his mother fittin
father Talal and two brothers fled from
Syria making it to Greece as refugees we
filmed back in the spring of 2017 when
after a lengthy wait the family attended
one of their first appointments with a
specialist consultant it was a day which
destroyed their hope that reaching
Europe would provide any sort of easy or
quick resolutions for Najib you feel
you feel nothing yeah no let's try this
type you feel it do you feel anything
here this is an automatic movement
really it doesn't any any any conscious
movement of his legs which had a good
inhale the other he had originally and
hanukkah heady and other lot it had kuru
do you think that there's any chance he
could walk again I think this is this
very simple in the whisper second
initial incursion al-assad man efficient
one of the first manager he could barely
look up from the pain he couldn't
breathe properly he was always vomiting
and his kidneys were failing and his
respiration was at 30% and declining
over subsequent months I visit Najib a
number of times in Greece on each
occasion his condition had deteriorated
by now aged 14 his family are struggling
to even lift the teenager out of bed or
into his wheelchair and they fear he may
not survive much longer now Jeebs
collapsing spine which still has
shrapnel in it has got visibly worse
pushing his abdomen to one side causing
him intense pain his family say they
never dreamed they would be stuck in
Greece a country overwhelmed by migrants
like this
let's do it kind of respond Adam look
luckily my supposed to do an eye on them
to go with what's a lot of on yeah
little but I believe he everyday yeah
but I do not feel in a very useful
energy it becomes clear the only way to
get a visa to go to Britain is for the
charity to guarantee funding for Najib's
treatment doctors in Greece are trained
most of them here in in the states they
are just as good
the surgeons there but unfortunately we
were told that rehabilitation for
Refugees can take much longer and it was
time sensitive it was all crowdfunding
that has always been crowdfunding none
of this has been on the NHL
hello goodwill Carbon donors we're here
in front of the visa application center
where Najib and his mom and our team are
waiting to see what happens five years
after the air strike which left him
paralyzed Najib is welcome to UK by
supporters of the charity which made it
possible he's been given the go-ahead
for spinal reconstructive surgery at
Great Ormond Street Hospital in London
how are you doing okay it's been a while
since I've seen Najib and again his
spine appears to have got worse Najib
knows the operation should dramatically
improve his quality of life but it's
still a daunting prospect
none that I feel same you see that's not
many of my whichever finally the day of
the operation arrives there's been a lot
of pain and tears along the way by now
Najib and his mother have been apart
from the rest of their family who are
still in Greece for four months and the
strain is showing
Thank You di jalan no it's I hadn't even
AG yeah penny damn Nanak my time finicky
money and he said this mean enough what
I'm holding at you
Dion York for my Najib can't get in and
out of his wheelchair without help he
can't sit up straight and he's in
terrible pain he's only here because of
the donations of well-wishers I think
you've come a long way for this day yeah
that's pretty good now excited about the
future
yeah consultant orthopaedic surgeon
Ramesh Nataraja
has come to see no geez he will carry
out the operation the surgery itself is
from t2 to this isn't a procedure which
will provide a miracle cure enabling
Najib to walk again but the spinal
reconstructive surgery should straighten
his spine and allow him to be able to
maneuver himself put in what is known as
a halo traction gesture on his skull to
ensure that the traction forces on his
spine allow us to fully spine act as
straight as we can hope I'll make a cut
in his back and after that I will put in
small screws onto his spine I think is
probably gonna be anywhere between 25 to
about thirty two screws really yeah
because at the end of the Ames is nice
to ensure that the construct itself
doesn't fail how complex is this
operation it is a very complex operation
yeah because you know the the the key
thing about the operation is that this
dissin operation where but there's other
bits of shrapnel in there as well so he
can make it a bit more sort of difficult
for us
the specialist team up daeho's deeper
into Najib's back to reveal his spine
each of the state-of-the-art rods and
screws to straighten his back must be
carefully positioned and secured an
x-ray if each one is taken and checked
several hours Eiland the surgeons reach
a huge fragment of shrapnel from the
airstrike still lodged in the Jeep's
back
they hope to remove it but it's simply
too deeply embedded their work is
painstaking and Najeeb is in the
operating theater for more than six
hours if it all goes well Najib should
be able to move independently for the
first time in nearly six years that
okhane sort of wiggle forward several
weeks later and Najib has been moved to
the Royal National Orthopaedic Hospital
in Middlesex fit the operation has been
a success
his mother pushed him in his old
wheelchair from Syria to Turkey before
getting a smuggler boat to Greece now
with his new motorized wheelchair the 15
year old is on the way to regaining his
independence and you probably heard me
they even actually long a clip of
liliane comes ashore Damon had again
World War II their new leader Ayman Nour
Danford knew Annie and I'm I'm sure he
says you know
oblah lamellae padam legitimize our
gamellia
kikuchi Sabah Lee Jung en en el más
Allah Hannah because she Ana demon
Mishima her because she a laconic dear
for honey and on Egypt are Durrani
Najib eonni Zara don't show a lot nicer
but rajim Allah know give people a
Telugu a new series examining when we
feel achieve now it is almost
unrecognizable he's with a straight back
he could take a full breath you can put
on his top on his own it might not sound
like a big thing but before he could
barely move his arm to move himself on
the sofa when we first met him two years
ago Najib is undergoing nearly a month
of rehabilitation but already he's able
to carry out basic tasks so easily taken
for granted
Kalyani table Melia Canyon e bar Y bar
would Goodland hurry
Halina criminal was Abdullah died at the
Rockaway vodkas for Lecter Anna Boch a
Quranic Tirico another lahmacun so at
lemony lovely well doing how does that
feel Najib and his mother want to stay
in the UK and hope the rest of their
family will be able to join them the
charity which helped them say their
campaign for Najib may be over but there
are still hundreds of other youngsters
who fled from war zones
who aren't getting the help they need